maybe time for the White House to really
panic because it looks like the media is
jumping off the Biden bandwagon after
another terrible poll this week it's
gotten so bad that Outlets are literally
asking Kamala if she's ready to take
over for Biden
are you prepared to be
commander-in-chief yes I am if necessary
you feel prepared for that possibility
uh and serbians vice president prepared
you for for that job yes
and others in the Press are practically
begging California governor Gavin Newsom
to get into the 2024 race
filing deadlines haven't passed
President Biden doesn't run why
shouldn't we consider you a likelihood I
think the vice president is naturally
the one lined up and the filing
deadlines are quickly coming to pass and
I think we need to move past this notion
that he's not going to run President
Biden is going to run uh and looking
forward to getting him reelected
all right Judge Jeanine Pirro what do
you think is going on in the media do
you think they're worried that he can't
win uh yeah and I think CNN is leading
the way on this thing I mean the fact is
that van Jones Tana bash no way to spin
this you know and as soon as they came
out with that you knew that something
was going on behind the scenes and Gavin
Newsom can talk all he wants about I'm
gonna sit here and let Kamala run uh and
I'm very impressed with her she didn't
chuckle through that thing why do you
think Gavin said that uh because he's
just trying to be a party loyalist until
he decides to jump in and I don't know
why Whitmer isn't jumping in I don't
know why Klobuchar all of them look 7
out of 10 people don't want Joe Biden to
run all right everyone is worried about
his competency let's not I mean there's
no elephant in the room anymore I mean
it's right out there and the bottom line
is that
um that even though Joe Biden has so
much going in his favor the truth is I
mean he went after he went after Donald
Trump and whether you think he did or
not I mean they've indicted them four
times and all of the things that they've
done to Donald Trump and yet everyone is
so close to beating Biden anyway so I
think the Democrats realize that they
can't win with him the more we go into
the fall and they've gotta they've got
to change horses Greg how do you see it
how do I see it I see it if Joe Biden
was just a skull on a pogo stick
slathered in Bengay but was up 10 points
they would be right behind him so it
doesn't mean like fetterman exactly this
is not for the benefit of the country
it's the benefit of the party why is the
median Revolt is it because Joe is unfit
nope too old nope too senile no two out
of touch it's because he's behind it
wouldn't matter if he was ahead this is
their Guy this is why they're turning on
him you know what it's like it's like
the way a hardcore football fan demands
his team trade their age in QB he's not
like saying he wants somebody else to
win they just want they want him out
because they're going to lose you'd
expect them to be looking at this as an
objective journalist saying like man
this guy's in trouble he's not all there
he's a danger to this country because he
can't think they're not saying that
they're saying he's gonna lose that
they're not journalists they're
partisans Martha so I think if you're
President Biden and you're watching
those responses you're kind of thinking
that you're in a good position
um if you watch Kamala Harris she
doesn't engender a lot of confidence
when she goes yep I'm ready sure I'm
ready nobody's going oh she oh that made
me feel a lot better so let's you know
elect Joe Biden and she'll be the vice
president and she'll be ready to go I
think she looks nervous when she answers
those questions I think that they look
at Gavin Newsom and you know Chuck Todd
almost begging him to run and Gavin
Newsom has run California into the
ground so if you're Joe Biden you look
at that and you go gee this is a very
thin bench and I am not too worried I
mean I think if Trump was going to run
against Kamala or Gavin he'd probably
feel confident
I'm not sure I think you can reach him I
don't have access to him like that but
you can ask him if I mean I I think it's
clear that he could wipe the floor with
both but go ahead are you guys
bedwetting
always and that's how I like it
um there's this myth that Democrats like
the liberal media but we do not this is
what happens all the time the liberal
media before the 2022 midterms red waves
coming guys right they're predicting up
to 40 seats so that was me that was me
and Jesse no it was obviously all
conservative media but it was also the
liberal media doing this scaring
everyone there were a few analysts that
were saying hold on guys it's not going
to be that bad and then it ended up
being a historic over performance it's
the same thing if you think back to the
2016 election where did the Hillary
Clinton server Story come from the New
York Times where did the uranium one
story come from the New York Times so
this isn't it as if people who work at
these institutions are working hand in
hand with Democrats they often serve up
the absolute worst stories but Democrats
as I led with we like to be scared
because we run better when we're scared
and this is what the polling is saying
right now polling captures a snapshot in
time and this particular moment in time
it's bad it's it's bad it's a bad time
well it's a bad time for both
supposed nominees right Joe Biden is
definitely Trump's ahead in the last two
polls well he's up by one which is well
there's a landslide if you're a
republican okay but over 50 percent of
Republicans say they're not going to
vote for him if he's convicted of
something and he's facing 91 counts so
you can say that the indictments are you
know Democratic stagecraft or whatever
but he's still going to have to go sit
through these trials and he's going to
face a jury and they're going to judge
him based on what he did so don't act
like it's all sunshine and roses for
Donald Trump you know who it was
sunshine and Roses were Nikki Haley
Nikki Haley was the one beating Joe
Biden by the most she was up six points
in the CNN poll National polls Don't
Mean a Thing sure because Mitt Romney
was up four points on Barack Obama at
this point in time but I'm just saying
that if there was someone who was not
Donald Trump on the Republican side at
this moment it looks like Nikki Haley is
having a little bit of a moment I think
she deserves it based on that debate
performance obviously you were up close
and personal there Martha I thought she
did amazingly well speaking from a
democratic perspective and the judge was
impressed with her as well we discussed
that but so you're Running Scared which
means you're scared okay I'm glad you
told the church we're scared rather be
I'd be scared if I were you too hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else